first things first what's that just yeah
your look in the gym is just something
else that brings attitude you look good
people see you coming in they think is
he gonna work out or do a magic act they
don't think it does come out and home
doesn't that this isn't magic what are
you eating
are you healthy man I'm a hella eater
brown rice broccoli all types of
vegetables man look I knew what I'm
supposed to here's my thing why help
death wow that doesn't you know why help
well I have a bit of a casual friendship
with death no I do I'm not trying to
help him but we do hang together my diet
I like fruit loops you know I don't use
the whole milk oh that's because you're
a you're a high school girl are you
getting ready for a big test today huh
that's her thing they come in different
colors he does real breakfast your man
you turn the milk old egg whites what
are you still eating cereal for dis age
you like to read the Box you like the
Box like to shake the box of look for
prize when you're done there's a problem
no sometimes you're surprised - father
nobody tells you when they grow up
enough is enough no more okay why would
you do some core work I don't feel like
you should lift which part which parts
the corner inside of it is a core and
underneath this thing that I've just
touched your core is in there we're
gonna let see where that is okay that's
it that's a good class Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
don't show don't Sheldon do you want to
sit down I like to lie down if I could
Sam gonna tell you a little story about
Kevin Hart it was a kid there's a kid
with a dream and guess what that dream
became reality you know why because I
wanted it to that's the difference
are you the kid in that drink read then
run with heart what do you have in your
body I have a heart I want you to run
with it
you don't you got you got to walk away
from the bedroom after sex body that
makes you go why did I do that I don't
walk away I back up like this and that
shows them that's what you just got get
more good yeah okay surgery is a small
but tasty treat look at that you had to
I just want you to know did you not the
only one around here with guns give me a
second the thing about me what I'm doing
get down it's just a date moment we can
get right back to it let me tell you a
little story that's pretty inspirational
was once a little kid and he had a dream
and he stuck to that dream it was mind
over matter and that kid's name was
Orville Redenbacher side-by-side okay I
should probably do mine this way for
ratings
[Laughter]
and that's what TV just got a little
dark
you take Vogue and have behind him
you're gonna pass to your partner Kevin
your success is dependent on him so is
yours for him question I'm a lot more
successful movies income likability how
people know him all around the world yes
he is my week or is it based off of all
that's a big part of it so your success
now has to drop to my level of success
sweetie I am married I don't know if
anybody else saw that but I'm mad
because she came at you with her how do
I have the time sir though I'm married
no he came at me almost as much as she
came at you two guys I'm in the parking
lot in half an hour honest you meet both
of us in a club you don't know who we
are you just see our bodies who are you
moving towards whoever's fighting here
what now
[Music]
no don't please no don't stop no just a
[ __ ] about something I did this is for
you man
you guys know I have my own sneaker at
Nike called the hustle heart so I got
you something what are you yelling you I
thought you were in here okay what size
do you wear a size seven seven no I'm
like a twelve and a half in a sneaker
yeah there you go
when I train in a sneaker that seven
size is too small
I picked the hustle high it doesn't fit
me and neither does she
dickie so please I Love You Man
I love you too this is a good day we
always cut out the part where you say
you love me
we always cut that out I don't know why
but I do man
you